[Music]
the most important thing a man can take
into combat is a reason why you're in
this fight boys you mark my words 19 men
attacked our country the 12 of you will
be the first ones to fight back it's us
we're going in you know I love you right
I would be remiss if I did not say to
you even in success the odds of you
coming home you're a hundred percent sir
we're coming
[Music]
why is not follow you take me to Taliban
I'll show you okay with psychosis he's
serious
alright who's written before anyone
can't kill Spring Break ghost pretty
hey this is we [ __ ]
[Music]
50 dozen okay to apply to her and yours
just an army of [ __ ]
you've just been handed the most
important mission of the free world
hold on our boys are gonna ride into
battle on horseback but chances are we
are not gonna make it out of this one
equipped now what happened back home
gonna happen again and again you know
each you got to make this decision
nothing I'd rather do
oh man thought you'd never ask
[Music]
where the hell do those come from
take out biggest guns first I have a
biggest gun cut the only way home is
waiting this is from the towers you
carry that with you